Carrie Keagan is here welcome Carrie you
got so much going on I guess right now
like like you're gearing up to have so
much going on right like it's done but
now everybody gets to find out about
that's what happens when you write a
book it's like entirely it you spend a
thousand days writing it and you feel
like you've been in a closet in the dark
by yourself feeling and then all of a
sudden everyone knows ya and and it is
all very exciting it's like yeah but
I've been living this for four years
yep four years no no well not exactly no
but yes I mean I feel like it has been
what's it about it's called everybody
curses I swear you can imagine um I mean
basically I I started in this business
interviewing celebrities on no good TV
and gtv calm and every a-list celebrity
could possibly think of was cussing
their ass off now how did you end up
getting that kind of access in the
beginning is it because you were one of
the first kind of giant youtube things
so he's very attractive
that helps oh thanks um well we started
out as a partner on YouTube yeah and I'm
sure that that helped but then I mean
you don't always get access just because
you're with YouTube right and we were
one of the first YouTube partners so we
definitely were not it wasn't because of
YouTube that we ended up getting all the
access but yet you just you cut your
teeth you just keep doing it you keep
you get into one and then you you don't
[ __ ] it up but you keep coming back and
they keep inviting you the celebrities
enjoyed it so we just kept coming back
how are they doing and hit on you I'm
sure all of them did um not as many as
you would think this is a very
professional thing these junkets in
these interviews you know how much
junkets is different but I mean yeah
ever sometimes you know you get an
accurate half hungover or whatever yeah
like right now are you hungover I'm
[ __ ] up right yeah are you dude it was
Halloween yesterday yet fine at the
Halloween parade Halloween's my favorite
holiday of the year I live for this [ __ ]
by the way that's the best sidestep of a
subject ever yeah I'm gonna try to have
sex with you oh my god did you see the
float
not as many as you would think yeah all
right
it's it I I wish sometimes that there
were more yeah you do but then not
really yeah yes that gets old
I imagine it does but it's also people
who are I wouldn't imagine that it does
if you're if you have accepted
celebrities no but if you're hot going
disguise hey I just leverage hey you're
almost entitled like they're expecting
wait wait I think you can actually take
out one word from that sense if you're a
girl oh and people are hitting on you
all the time I mean pretty much if
you're breathing and you have the like
slight maybe a boob someone's going to
be hitting on you all the time yeah and
that's just the way it goes
any gets any get so sometimes old right
being said I'm not telling anybody to
stop right because yeah we're the only
thing worse than that getting old is if
it stops happening entirely wait what
hap right you're like oh no yeah
complain about signing autographs then
people stop asking like [ __ ] it wish
somebody would notice that I'm here in
my not go anymore
yeah right right reporting or hosting
this oh yeah so I'm on Celebrity
Apprentice that starts in January and
they it's a whole new thing they are
filming it in la Hache Ward's Nagar is
now the host um and it's fun who else is
on it lots of people that's hella mad
iseman Zhaan it from American Ninja
Warrior yeah yeah Matt's on it um
Boy George Vince Neil Jon Lovitz who is
hysterical by the yeah he doesn't go
anywhere without his dog Jerry have you
met Jerry I'm not much that we haven't
met Jerry you guys never I've had a
cousin who did stand-up named Jerry
years ago I don't think it's um Jerry is
this tiny little dog with this
ridiculous underbite and he doesn't go
anywhere without Jerry you have to look
him up like google his face he's
ridiculous looking were you were you
bummed because I'm a ridiculous
Celebrity Apprentice fan are you
I mean I've watched every season like
religiously really crazy so you'll be
watching this is it yeah but if I was on
Celebrity Apprentice I found out Donald
there's a rename it apprentice would
hear nobody apprentice
you know they have the other apprentice
to the other uh but I'd be bummed out of
my friend Donald wasn't hosting why cuz
I used to look I liked watching the show
with Donald was hosted well maybe you'll
like it better with the Governator do
you think so potentially how long how
long were the boardrooms how long were
they yeah I mean someone go on for hours
honestly they they cut it down for TV
right but they don't make a quick
decision which is awkward cause Trump
endorsed him and said hey I can't
picture of a better a guy to do this
he's my friend and now Arnold's going
that's the first Republican I'm not
gonna vote for is any tension between
those two guys oh uh I'm sure I'm sure
that the stuff that's going on in
politics right now is just messy yeah
but I have to say there's one thing that
I'm really happy about this whole Trump
situation is um the word [ __ ] is now
like being said on every single news
station it's my things not being used to
describe me I mean that just makes me
happy and it also makes me happy as a
woman in this business as a woman in
life that all this stuff is now coming
out that we have all dealt with have you
done guys like like something like I
grabbed your [ __ ] I know oh not that
way Oh I mean figuratively right but
it's annoying you know I don't and I'm
not gonna sit here and complain about ya
guys do stuff like Trump is talking
about like you as a guy I would never
just grab somebody's crotch right dirty
guy but I wouldn't do as a human being
you shouldn't be grabbing someone's
[ __ ] what I'm saying do you do you
have stuff like that happened that like
wow what he said it really is believable
it that guys are doing that yes in the
business yes it is amazing how much you
have to go through just to just to get
your foot in the door I mean when they
say people sleep their way to the top or
[ __ ] their way to the top they're not
kidding so what like did somebody do
that to you or try to do that to you
when you were newer like now they
couldn't get away with it but I mean
when you first started yeah I mean when
I first got to LA I'm not going to name
names but he was a pretty prominent
agent um we had a connection through a
friend so he was like hey I come out to
dinner so we went out to dinner and
literally we had you know few drinks in
he was like so what why don't you just
you should probably just [ __ ] me because
I'm not going to rep you anyway what why
would you spend a rep somebody yeah
right wait devil's advocate I think he
just wanted to make sure that his lines
were drawn so that he was governed yeah
you should say you should probably just
[ __ ] me because otherwise I'm not gonna
rep yeah I'm not gonna rep you anyone
ever say that yeah nope well that shows
you how smart agents can be yes so that
wasn't an aphrodisiac for you that
wasn't a oh yeah totally I still see him
around yeah yeah and actually he's since
apologized
that's a scumbag thing to say with
somebody's like you know you could try
to get laid but to do that when somebody
is like legitimately trying to make it
in the business is just shitty but how
does all this nice la though I mean I
don't know how much it happens um just
another - yeah yeah yeah but it pretty
much is yeah it's so much fun is it yeah
yes fun this is great yeah every girl
that I've heard from that's come out
here all the like host or whatever they
try to make it The Young Ones
all of them are have people that exact
same scenario is happening to him
because I think at a certain point when
you get into a position of power you
don't even realize how degrading some of
the things you say are because the rules
don't apply because because no one's
watching right and if I need something
from you I'm gonna pretty much take a
lot of your [ __ ] and they're because I
need something from you what is
something other than that that somebody
has said to you that whether you did it
or not but you just felt like well
that's [ __ ] unusual to hear somebody
do oh god there's so many things um ah
well I mean the one story that's coming
to mind is a little bit different I was
working on a network here that no longer
exists and CBS is bad yes sir I I was a
regular on that network and all of a
sudden one day they just stopped hiring
me and you know a year or so later I ran
into the head of that network who wasn't
was no longer gonna be the head of that
network
and I was like oh you know how come it's
weird you know I wish I could work with
you guys again I don't know what
happened he's like honestly the women
executives um just thought your boobs
were offensive and I was like um no I'm
getting it from the other side right now
how could you be offended by that's like
go on and say I didn't like that there
was two Lamborghinis am I wrong with
people I'm gonna start calling him that
yeah that's that's that's shitty so it
was no jealousy jealousy yeah and they
couldn't just said like for the show
could you dress a certain way that I
mean when I did the show they had a stag
word robe department that was dressing
listen you okay but it's kind of hard to
hide the leg it it's impossible for me
to hide right now you haven't you
noticed Jim as you know oh I know I look
eyes only oh that's it well you're
you're charming as she is Carrie is out
I'll tell you well endowed okay well I
don't I don't look down that's nice for
you yes so I wasted this outfit James
just an old romantic down here look down
here no lower and she can always tell
any guys catching creepy glance like a
glance when they look alike I just
couldn't noise tell us oh it's
hysterical to me when I'm meeting people
even you know executives or whatever I'm
meeting people and you always like hey
and you know there's always that quick
glance down it's hard not to yeah what
about people go in for the way too tight
hug oh you know what I mean because they
want to cop a feel
that's so [ __ ] creepy did you start
pressed that reminds me of that Trump
and Billy Bush thing when they got came
off the bus I reckon come on give us a
ha yeah like ah I feel bad now we hugged
burn when you came in dude I hugged you
harder than you hugged me no I know but
I'm a hug me but I made this uh-huh I
thought that was just my back crack now
just bury your face in her neck mother
last time I actually saw you was in New
York right after we roasted Boomer
Esiason that to the Rosewood we went to
the Friars Club after and I could not
remember who we had just I was just
anything who heroes last time and you uh
we were talking for a while and then
somebody dragged you off
that was talking to is it Jerry Lewis no
no you just wanna talk I forget who but
you seem like you're being hustled off
so how do you end up like after all
these interactions with scumbags how do
you end up like I feel like so many
people would not make friends with
anyone anymore
like I just I could talk to anybody
anymore if this is like is it's a you
know differently days I feel like that
for sure
words like every conversation needs here
life I guess you just have to roll with
the punches at a certain point I have to
just own the fact that my tits are here
yes people are going to look at them mad
at it anymore right also if I want to
get somewhere in this business I have to
put up with a certain amount of crap
right and that you just keep rolling you
just you got to like put up the walls
and just I don't know it's aside from
that example that you gave it the with
the women not feeling comfortable with
your breasts do you think that not
sleeping with people has cost you jobs
oh for sure it has yes I've met with
producers of movies and directors and
things
abso-fucking-lutely well I know they
don't come right out and say it
rightio most guys yeah because that
would be gross most guys so what what is
what is the way they'll phrase it we're
you know we both know what's being said
but yeah they can't be proved in court
right well yeah oh is that Dee Snider up
in the hallway yeah my god sorry
another Celebrity Apprentice yeah you
did I did yeah everybody gets roasted
some fava beans and a nice Chianti yes
so like what are they where they how do
you find out that that's the reason that
you didn't get the job or do you just
understand the phone just know I think
the first couple of times you're like
hey what I thought we got along so well
yeah and then no yeah no we get along
that well nope we didn't get along at
all well one element of our relationship
was missing yeah
what will the ocean write this I hope
when you're younger and all that's
happening do you think to yourself I
don't know why I have so much integrity
I gotta just it maybe I should just do
this or has it always been like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna [ __ ] people to get
jobs um I think in the very beginning
potentially um you start to question but
that's
why I think Hollywood is so [ __ ] up
right is because you then start to
internalize it and go oh is it should
maybe I'm doing it wrong right should I
be doing this you start taking it out on
yourself you get your insecurities start
to kick in and you're like whoa I need
to I need to put out in order to do that
I need to you know start doing things
differently and like lowering my
standards yes not looking at it this way
Karimi yeah yeah so did you ever
compromise that and regret it no yeah no
and I talk about that in my book as well
the struggle of being a girl is real and
no at a certain point you just go you
know what I'm I did this for me I'm
doing this I'm going to keep my
standards and everybody standards are
different if you feel like you need to
[ __ ] your way to the top right and you
feel good about that then bless you yeah
I do I wish I could you should [ __ ] your
way to the top yeah every time I
function when I drop like performance
that makes me sad me too like you be
good I feel like you'd be a generous
lover I am yeah I mean I get I get in
there and I try to stick around till the
job's done
you do yeah it's just cool the way you
talk about it yeah you know I'm sexy I
keep it kind of sexual Yeah right right
discharged get in there until the job's
done
you know I do what how do you feel about
oral sex it's my favorite thing in the
world
you see every guy in the world says that
I know they do but I'm telling it's my
favorite
I've told too many embarrassing truths
about sex um I love oral sex even if
they have a vagina yes I know what I did
I found enjoying that yeah and I prefer
a vagina that's a bit uh what's the word
I not not not necessarily the perfect
looking ones I like in their big
personality drug versus I've driven
vaginas such as what now I am NOT a fan
aficionado of vaginas I don't mind the
larger ones like a small one tonight
like when the wind blows you exactly
what it looks like you could work like a
marionette
yeah those how do you know can you you
know how they say you can tell when a
man's penis looks like by his fingers
it's not true well it kind of is I
believe that that is true but
can you gauge a woman's labia skinny
little fingers yeah exactly yeah lady
accurate nobody bites his nails for I
always get a presence that will that
will help like white spandex shorts
that's how I can tell you do yeah but I
like oral sex so much because it is so
much less of a risk and I'm talk for a
living I used to smoke I like to eat
compulsively I'm scent driven so I've
always kind of enjoyed camp oral
fixation is what you're saying
very much like Michael zeglen thank yous
catch ever
yeah you don't worry about getting
cancer like Michael Douglas you know if
you're gonna get it what better way to
get it that's true
[ __ ] Catherine zeta-jones that's true
nobody's gonna sit there and be like
like if you smoke and you get cancer
people are gonna call you an idiot but
if that's how you get cancer
yeah people high-five you exactly is
worth it although you can just try and
see their prescription for that pill
that you can get now for the HPV virus
but don't you need to be a certain young
age for that you're supposed to take it
yeah when you're I think you know
adolescent I should find out about that
I don't think I've ever had a HPV but I
don't think so no doesn't just go away
dunno either have it or you don't know
no but I think I've intensified in have
it or they can't test for it yeah okay
there's probably just so much other [ __ ]
in there for you that it would just be
under everything you know be surprised I
think so yeah very sharp so you enjoyed
it's weird though that they got Arnold
to host Celebrity Apprentice because for
all the for all the [ __ ] that Donald has
in his in his past you know that's been
coming out as this election has I mean
Arnold's also a pig you know ain't gonna
read the phrase that I bought on eBay
Arnold is also had a couple of dubious
or questionable things said alleged that
stuff first of all has anything to do
with my experience with it on umbrellas
he was always a gentleman to me he
actually he invited all of us up to his
house
really no he invited you and he told you
everyone else was coming no everyone was
there they all said no proof nice is his
house it's pretty great and it's got
like Governor paraphernalia and
Terminator [ __ ] all over it's cool keeps
all his [ __ ] yeah he loves the
terminators they have Attorney office
I didn't see the outfit which I saw the
skull ahaha that's pretty awesome I'll
be back
I do Arnold's impression he also had a
mini horse here's a mini heart like a
living mini horse like a real live mini
horse like in his backyard
she just roams around Wow she's real
cool I guess when you're Arnold and
you're making that kind of money and
you're that kind of famous like you had
a real horse oh you don't like that but
if you have a real horse then you can't
just let it roam around your kitchen
it's like a dog in the house yes like
inside yeah my shits all over there's a
[ __ ] they hire someone to follow with a
shovel exactly now you can put normal
diapers on them you deceive a diaper on
his horse I didn't see the diaper on but
we weren't running in and out of the
house either so
Arnold's house smells like a stable yeah
right you two grew up broken exactly
just just farm animals called musky
that's it he likes animals he's got big
I heard he hit those head parties with
elephants and stuff like that like so
yeah yeah did you end up making any
enemies I don't know even though you
maybe probably can't I can't actually
tell you anything about it can you tell
me if you made any enemies and I want to
ask you who I can tell you that when you
put 16 celebrities in a room there's
gonna be some drama that's great that's
we're gonna have to tune in to find out
why yes drama yeah I'm definitely in a
tune in our [ __ ] love Celebrity
Apprentice
when is it come on January same time the
book comes out January 2nd did you do
that on purpose
what comes out January 10th like really
it was a happy accident yeah yeah let's
works out for me though that read
accident yeah wait a minute January 10th
January 2nd okay now I'm gonna take a
guess yeah
and say the Kari got thrown off the
first week because she is promoting the
book the week after she got thrown off
or she anusaniya booted off something
and that's it yeah that's a big
assumption
yeah there's you I'm not good I'm not
good at Celebrity Apprentice guessing
I'm always wrong but it is true yet she
got a release in early in January
because if she waits till February she's
already been gone off the show for three
weeks that's it and there's always heat
around June you get booted all people
know what happened why'd you get kicked
alright
right also it could have just been a
happy accident that that's how I know
I'm a happy accident
thank you mama Norton there are there
are a lot of guys I was reading before
you came in
the story about your interview with
Justin Timberlake where it's like it was
just about his dick Lacock yeah yeah
legit what happened was you just had the
transcript in there here's what I talked
to Justin Timberlake and she just
wouldn't let it go what when you have a
joint like innuendo and write you can
work it into every there are so many
dick puns out there right why not use
all of them on Justin Timberlake who is
not shy of talking about his dick in the
box right
he doesn't mind he doesn't mind so I
mean that's just one of many wonderful
interviews like what guy would mind
talking there's no guy - talking about
his dick I don't think because long as
you can make up stories about well
unless you're ashamed of it like yeah
bad circumcision uh-huh I didn't have a
bad circumcision it up yes you did no I
did his penis why do you know this Jim
because we're the Oh
that means we pay together you know he
told us you guys came when he was 19
yeah yeah I didn't get circumcised till
I was 19
please tell me okay I don't know if
anybody's watching shameless but one of
the care yeah shameless concert no my
Z's like 2013 or whatever yeah um ow
see he got yeah the character and
shameless gets hard-ons all the time so
he has to keep going back and getting it
fixed it keeps ripping the stitches I
don't think it's possible though I mean
it really for the recovery [ __ ] her
how long it'll s the recovery long - the
recovery was like it was probably a
solid week of recovery and then it was
still like not ready for use how long
till you could actually use it do you
feel like you know what Bob it felt like
no we can't no Lorena he doesn't matter
it was probably I mean I would say and I
might have been more precautious than
most whew three weeks is when it's like
okay that's my penis now because they're
swelling and there's scars and stitches
and everything do you just think of your
grandmother for three weeks like haha no
he couldn't get hard-on well no I might
feel gross right now at least for the
first week you can get hard-ons after
like the first week or so but are in the
first big it would hurt right yeah but
like your dick hurts so much you're not
getting hard-on
like it's not an issue so Morningwood is
not something that just happens
naturally then when you're know cuz I
mean it's just a we don't give you
anything like saltpeter or any kind of
pill to take uh to keep that it's a good
point to at night you dreaming who knows
ya know it was never it was never cuz
Jude you dick is all bandaged up and
wrapped up or a gel on the tip of your
dick so just numb it topically I guess
you could if you really had cocaine
whatever works but there was literally
like Kari I don't know how much detail
you want to get into here but there's
like I want to see it
there was alright there's like at one
point right so like they wrap it up and
they go there's like a gauze in there
right like under there under the
bandaging and I saw this big like purple
what looked like a gelatin almost pad
and I know that must be what they meant
by the padding gauze thing under it and
like as I started to like undo it I
realized like no that's my body swelled
up you know like that to it that was his
dick look like Peter Boyle and Young
Frankenstein yeah I mean can I tell you
it healed up beautifully did it yes I
think you should show yes but later on
Instagram you're right right right but
at the time no it was uh it was a
traumatic why did you wait till you were
19 like why did you decide to tell me
what was happening should I tell her
tell him what was happening so you met a
girl and she didn't like the sleeve no
it was it was it was well it was worse
than that you met a dude there's love
the sleeve passive-aggressive right
exactly he cheated on me so I took his
favorite sleeve away um yeah so uh you
know there's a I didn't know it was
called phimosis until dr. Steve called
up and talked about that it was called
did you know it was called phimosis Jim
no I did not there's a condition
it sounds like dick cheese is this it's
not dick cheese well have you ever been
with a man read some phimosis on the
ride cracker have you ever been with a
man that's not circumcised yeah you have
okay so you you prefer I honestly
someone just asked me this I honestly
don't have a preference the different
the problem with uncircumcised yeah is
you have to just really be vigilant
about taking care of the cleanliness of
the area right otherwise you can give me
all kinds of [ __ ]
right and also I mean you know you aside
most especially American women think
uncircumcised penises are ugly and what
no pieces are beautiful well I think so
too but um but really so famosa so you
may not know about this yes Sam is an
artist and his mouth is the palate you
know how I gifted the foreskin you have
to pull it down so there's like a hole
in the top of the foreskin and that's
what the did your dick comes out of well
what would happen if the hole in the top
of the foreskin was only big enough that
you could piss out of it but not big
enough that you could get your dick out
at the top of it Wow so the hairless
penis was never exposed so the turtle
that can't get his head out of a shell
exactly that would suck right it's like
you know when you stretch when you put
on a rubber glove and you just keep
stretching it but you can't get your
hand out of it it's just like pulling
against it who would hurt uh no not
unless see this is where it would hurt
the skin would just expand with it so it
would be but it would just be wrapped up
all the time all the time but at first
the urologist was like you got to do
exercises to stretch out the thing and
then and that's when it like if you do
it aggressively that [ __ ] hurts it's
like you gotta exercises the things that
are going on in my brain like you have
to just sit there pulling on your
foreskin you know come on you can do it
three and one and two right right right
um so now that you know the difference
between having it and not having it
foreskin I mean right would you
recommend people get circumcised of
course really of course number one
there's no risk to being circumcised is
there no reward to having your foreskin
people are like some people say sex is
better because you're head of your dick
isn't exposed all the time I thought it
would be but I don't think look I'm not
I'm clipped thank you nobody asked you I
am too you just you just said so proud
of yourself
but like no I mean there are a lot of
women that think circumcised dicks
ugly uncircumcised - yeah uncircumcised
dick sir - you in the [ __ ] foreskin
doesn't come down and they see about
this [ __ ] take off a turtleneck yeah
though it's just because that's what
they've seen right well it is what it is
and they see less of them I love that a
an interview with Justin Timberlake is
what brought this entire conversation
what did you want to know about his
penis he had phimosis I've been the most
you want to know everything about his
penis what do you want to know about Oh
what I'd want to know what Justin's
packing I would too we can ask Jessica
that shouldn't tell us though he'd be
more likely to tell us if it's over six
if it's a bit 7 or 7 or above hit by be
happy to tell us if it's under he would
probably not yeah
have you any like he's doing all right
down there have you had any public
celebrity boyfriends no not you Bobby uh
who you dated that we know in public
yeah I mean I don't know about it but
that people know about so it's not like
you're telling tales out of school you
know uh I mean if you google me you'll
see a few names up there all right Jim
you asked a question I'm in Google okay
Tom now are you are you do you not like
to mention the names because there was a
bad blood or do you no no no no never be
friends with your exes always oh you are
I'm only not friends with one who is it
because he's a dick okay
Genda oh god that was forever ago and
why why did you not remain friends like
how is he doing because I he he [ __ ]
me over on something we were I asked him
to do something and he didn't do it and
so then once you've betrayed me
[ __ ] you yeah you're like a warrior in
that respect right financial yeah yeah
it wasn't financial which if it was
money you know money gets complicated it
wasn't money Oh Sam comment I found one
of a celebrity boyfriend comment Sam are
you in this relationship right now
not if you're seeing it online this says
Michael Sheen from masters of sex I
don't know Michael she knows you ever
seen that show no but I boy you just
missed it really thank God
Michael Sheen there was a worse choice
he's actually in a very happy
relationship with Sarah Silverman at the
moment oh I see her for a couple of
years so he just likes funny ladies huh
apparently it's got good taste I have to
say that's very humble of you yeah but
before that he was with um Kate
Beckinsale for a bunch ears man
Beckinsale yeah she's uh she's gorgeous
did I do she British mm-hmm yeah you did
I did Leno with yeah you thought she you
thought something was gonna happen
really did you think you had a chance no
but you did you went back on the radio
show and talked about I had a chance but
she had said that she wanted to come see
a show and she was in New York so I and
then you tried very hard to make sure
that that information got to her
absolutely and then did she enjoy the
show there was some kind of a
communication because the number I had
wasn't hers oh no no was her assistant
so then how'd she get the information no
for assistant gave at aura texted the
assistant I thought it was her so it was
like I'm naked right now would you like
to come over no she could see by the
photo it was just hey it's Jamie Mars
okay well this is her assistant no oh
okay so so Nertz so she gave you she was
like all here you know I'd love to come
see a show reach out to this number and
you were like oh sure Kate Beckinsale
just gave me her phone number and it was
her assistants number she was very funny
and racy we were sitting on that
in-between on the commercial break
is that right yes she was lovely I mean
we girls have to be careful there always
has to be like you know the fat ugly
friend or whatever you know what I mean
like there's always somebody in the in
between yeah so that if things go
horribly wrong and she finds out you're
a psycho there's a way to run away so do
you think that's what happened she
googled Jim Norton and was like ah I
don't know if I wanna I mean obviously
she was drunk when she gave you this
probably a little [ __ ] up yeah yeah
exactly
well she'd actually give it she was
passed out I just took her phone person
called myself in smoke do you like uh uh
having a celebrity dating pool or do you
want to get out of that it's not
necessary to me I just either it's just
the thing is is that who I'm surrounded
with right all the time so
you're in that pool of people people
yeah you just sort of that's what I mean
I could end up with Jim any second man
whoa yeah I mean a lot of women say that
not Kate Beckinsale that's never true
they just say it okay they do they just
say to get out the door and then when
they're gone it's like no we're not oh
my god oh my god a date though are you
yeah Alex nothing in your past will
bother me right I'll make it all
perverted and enjoy it yeah but
everything in your past will bother them
that's a great point yeah it takes a man
take doesn't everybody think they're a
[ __ ] catch though um I thought she I
thought she was gonna say Oh
everybody thinks your past is gonna
bother this you didn't say that does
everybody think they're a [ __ ] jet
you know I don't think I'm a catch you
don't know I think I'm a great rebound
but like have you ever met anyone that's
like oh my god I'm the worst person
today yes and they dated me that's Jim's
dating pool actually yeah we know do
you're a catch um I think that I'm
pretty I'm I'm cool like yeah not much
bothers me and I'm pretty open to a lot
of things I like new adventures I'll try
stuff well if you're spanked a guy sure
ah cycle right please it's that really
is that I'm not think I mean spank but
that just says something about a lot of
wouldn't have it like that that's that
sadness first step that's that dance the
Gateway absolutely marijuana right right
so once you get him on heroin it's like
it's pretty much the same yeah if you're
gonna sure yeah yes thank I know you
would you do you like doing that or is
it weird for you
no it's weird for me but you know you
more try it once or twice and then are
you more semesters your dominant person
Sara Lee but I also like it when a guy
is like you know in charge or whatnot in
charge what I mean but you know a lot of
women will say I like when a male and as
a man in bed exactly like a man yeah
it's uh it feels so not politically
correct to say that but it's true that
one man to be amazed I'll do that deli
even if I'm losing my erection I'll go
goddamn Chevy's Drive good I'll say man
stuff let's go yeah Tim the two
we try to make up for it you're just
reading Tim Allen grunts oh yeah
absolutely
cuz I'm going down now y'all see man
stuff football yell I wouldn't say that
but doesn't sound pleased me but you
know physically they want a guy to be a
certain it is what it is it's a dominant
women feel that way cuz you're you're
very in charge all day you know what the
[ __ ] you're doing you you know you're
very capable a lot of women like that
like they tend to get confidence and on
any level is sexy
Fisher Plus as somebody who's been in
show business for a minute you you've
you've survived you know what I mean
which means that right which means that
you you have to fight
you know remain in show business yeah I
don't need to fight with you in order
for us to have good sex this is I'm not
one of them no I just you have to fight
there so when you get home you don't
need all the fighting in the end the
area that's you that's yeah I submit a
little bit because in life yeah you
don't have the option Yeah right yes I
don't want to have to make all the
decisions all the time right right
have you been in relationships where
you're the breadwinner yeah do you like
that I think your hand it's fine until
I'm not making any money in minutes I go
yeah what are you what kind of job did
the guy have that you were in the bread
musicians come on what else would they
be stand-ups in the arts yeah yeah stand
up so have a more consistent way of
making money I think musicians is hard I
mean I said that's a rough gig the band
breaks up then what you have nothing
right you know that's a hard [ __ ] go
just okay but I mean stent to me
stand-up is the hardest thing on the
planet you what you guys do is is like
bow down to you it is so it's you're up
there naked telling everyone they're
laughing I mean I have a whole chapter
in the book about stand-ups they're
they're actually my favorite people in
the world to interview have you dated
stand-ups uh no not properly I don't
know all the psychoses dizzily odd stuff
with with comics but yeah comics like
are decent interviews because comics
will give information comfortably you're
interviewing people there's nothing
worse than someone who won't give
information that's all you ask for
it's my job to ask questions your job to
ask questions but if someone won't
answer them or gives like one-word
answers actors can be shitty oh yeah not
always some athletes can be shitty I
talked about that in my book too
bad bad interviews there there I mean
I've luckily not had a ton boys a better
yet
oh god Bruce Willis is the worst [ __ ]
was he really terrible I don't know
Bruce so I don't know what he's like
he's an interview why was he better got
a whole chap I heard he's a giant penis
by the way have you yes I have well I
guess you can be a bad interview when
you know you have a giant dick you have
a bit bit you're a bad interview because
you have a giant dick that's it never
say anything I'll just keep pointing why
he's ready but his head right now you
know you have to you have to read the
book to get the whole story but yeah I
didn't nutshell yeah ultimately he what
I thought he was gonna be which everyone
growing up that who knew who Bruce
Willis was like I was obsessed I thought
he was amazing he was like the perfect
guy to me in every way right and and
then I met him and it was like holy [ __ ]
and you know I tried to have fun with
him the man had zero sense of humor Wow
boy I don't know was he rude he was rude
he got up and walked out on me I'm just
saying what was the last thing you said
before he walked out you have to read
the book for that I can't get okay I
think not you don't even wear the end
that's fair but was it going poor were
you being confrontational or too
personal no I never get confrontational
I literally made a joke okay and he
didn't like that you didn't like my joke
well this is if you're gonna take this
seriously I'm leaving what wasn't even
that but anyway it was it's just it's a
sad thing but what I did realize is that
when you meet people that you know when
you meet your heroes they always tell
you don't meet your heroes yeah but
sometimes when bad things happen to you
huh you take it as a learning experience
right can you grow from it right I
haven't had any heroes be real dicks I
know gene Simmons was once but then that
every time I've seen him after that he
was great
gene Simmons used to be my business
partner was he really yeah you know gene
can be a little touch-and-go sometimes
she relishes and being an [ __ ] he
does what was your business partner I
dunno good TV oh he was one of the one
of the people involved he was that's all
imagine he never flirted with you yeah
it's just part of his DNA it really is
yeah but is he good at it though cuz he
is gene Simmons so I guess the thing is
I wonder sometimes how much he was
actually is he actually a like a real
ladies man or did women just flock to
him because he's gene Simmons the demon
and like everybody loves swagger and
everybody loves like a confident
musician and so how much was he getting
of those four thousand women he was
banging like how much of that was purely
because he had a bassist well he wasn't
[ __ ] he's a math teacher right wing's
I guarantee when he's teaching math and
queens he was not but if my math teacher
spit blood out in during class totally
banging him so what was your
determination after you get to know him
he's always been really good to me and
was he good ladies man or was it because
you I don't I'm really I'm still lost
because now like he's getting older and
older now he's married like yeah
everything's changed and so it's it's
hard to really gauge if and plus by the
way I watched him interact with a lot of
different women whether we were working
with them or just people would come up
and be like oh my god jeans mmm such a
fan he would always give people whether
it was a woman or a man a story
something to remember that exact moment
and it could have been the most
misogynistic thing you've ever seen like
he'll grab a girls tits or whatever she
doesn't get mad cuz it's gene Simmons
now is that swagger is that because your
genes attendee able yeah he's a but one
thing about gene it's funny that I've
mentioned us before he's he's a
tremendously patriotic guy like he
[ __ ] loves the United States allows
American loves America because when he
came here as a kid his mother's in a
concentration care he is an amazing
story like we had was a Dan Rather
interview uh which was great that that
he did know who doesn't like gene
Simmons should watch that it's like that
seems like that's who the real guy is
right behind all the [ __ ] I'm in kiss
stuff he's very likeable he thinks is
he's very likeable at night I'm
addressing story no but in that he's
very humble
oh he's relatable in a weird way yeah
you see him differently than that that
larger-than-life thing that you see yeah
you just see now you just see a [ __ ]
guy who likes his who cares about his
mom yeah but he's very very likable in
that interview
my mom too so anybody no that doesn't
that give me some credibility I guess
you're likable to that that must be why
you're likeable so is the book more uh
m-mother just turned 99 by the way she's
alive she's alive oh no what a [ __ ]
terrible show w she was dead for seven
years my grandmother mr. 99 she's been
in a graveyard hurry exactly cool she's
not know my great-grandmother her mother
what you get of her birthday um love
okay she's she's got a little bit of
dementia right now so she she wouldn't
remember anyway you know who you are
sometimes
oh but even sometimes it's not bad when
you're 99 yeah no it's great but my my
great-grandmother died when she was 105
my grandmother now is now 99 I feel like
I'm gonna be around for a while
chuckling to me that's great nice long
life but 99 is [ __ ] uh you gotta make
it one more year hundred right have to
yeah how about your mommy mom life yeah
everybody's alive okay Wow sorry my
other two grandparents have passed but
everybody in the immediate field but the
women live other men dying earlier or
the women uh funny enough both
grandfathers yeah hmm yes interesting
yeah the Kegan women are driving them
too early great they are driving crazy
they were lucky to have what they got no
that's good sign for you though the
women have longevity in your that just
means 72 more books so you excited for
Celebrity Apprentice yeah for people to
see everyone to see it yeah it's gonna
be it's gonna be cool what are you
excited to see everybody on the cast
again oh yeah cuz you got to do have you
done the finale now or is that done live
well they usually do it live I'm not
sure how they're doing it so you don't
know so the Celebrity Apprentice has not
yet been named you know who the final
two are oh yeah no no nobody knows but
nobody that hasn't happened yet
yeah no huh ha ha ha I'm looking forward
to seeing it I'm also looking forward to
everybody going out and getting
everybody curses I swear you can
pre-order it on Amazon now uh so if you
want it comes out January 10th preorder
it now what you could do is you do you
can pre-order the [ __ ] out of it you can
pre-order the [ __ ] out of it and then on
Christmas be like i pre-ordered you this
book I love that it's still a great
Christmas gift I'm gonna pre-order all
of them for you guys I'm giving them
gifts for stocking stuffers yes
everyone yes I love that and it's kind
of accommodate its it's your story of
surviving in this business as well as
the crazy interviews and stuff that
you've been a part of that's a little
bit of everything a little bit of my
potty mouth depravity I love it